le compte du sucre et du riz texte de
colline
illustration huguette payet histoires
traditionnelles de l'île bourbon chez
azalées éditions
il était une fois une très jolie
princesse qui s'appelait ombrines elles
habitaient le pays du sucre c'était un
pays merveilleux au lieu-dit le carrosse
la princesse vivait dans un château en
sucre qui embaumait la fraise la banane
la vanille tous les parfums que les
habitants souhaitaient ajouter à loder
d'où sa mère du sucre de canne
les allées du parc était plantée de
sucettes et de bonbons multicolores
tout pouvait être mangé toute
marchandise se paient dans cette monnaie
sucre et
les tables à sucre recevait les petits
cônes précieux qui étaient utilisés pour
construire murs fenêtres et portes du
stade et félicie cuisait le sucre pour
en faire le caramel qui servirait à
coller les cônes entre eux il y ajoutait
un peu de vanille de cannelle du sirop
de goyavier ou de fraise cela faisait
deux drôles de bure pas très 3 collants
et très odorant combine mails et j'ai de
temps en temps
la chapelle abritait de magnifique
statue sculptée dans de grands blocs de
sucre blanc à noël
ombre in rester des heures devant la
crèche dans le petit jésus avait été
sculptée avec grand soin par théodore
boulanger confie zié du roi
le bonheur régné au pays du sucre
jusqu'au jour où aubry tomba malade elle
dépérit sept ans qu'il fallut l'a couché
sur une table à sucre le roi et la reine
pleurer tellement que leurs larmes
commencèrent à faire fondre leur trône
les paille-en-queue inquiet pour leur
princesse prévint oiseaux la vierge
merle de maurice tuit-tuit et take qui
vinrent à tour de rôle veiller sur elle
l'abbé ressent de leurs chants mélodieux
il fut fait appel au médecin de
l'hôpital qui venait du pays lointain de
la pointe des galets celui-ci ausculte à
ombrines eddy sentencieusement il lui
faut des sucres lents toutes les
personnes présentes se regardèrent
chacun cherche à savoir si l'autre
savait ce qu'était un sucre lent mais
non sans avouer son ignorance devant le
roi et la reine
un jeune homme seul l'audace de
s'adresser au souverain car hombre n'est
lui c'est met en secret et il vole elle
a sauvé
majesté dit il j'entends dû parler d'un
pays appelé la rizière de la fontaine où
l'on cultive une denrée précieuse
appelé riz ce rire ans les habitants
très fort
ne s'agirait-il point de cela
si fait mon ami dit le médecin au grand
soulagement du jeune homme
majesté si vos biens autorisés jeu
partir en chercher même s'il faut pour
cela enjamber la terrible grande ravine
gardé par les barbapapa géante et
traverser le pays des sucettes enchanté
chose dite chose faite le jeune homme
qui s'appelait justin enfourcha son beau
destrier et s'en fut à la conquête du
pays dure et cela lui demande a beaucoup
de courage
udu d'abord franchir le dangereux fleuve
de sirop brûlant toujours rouge de
colère puis il réussit à s'enfuir des
marécages de chocolat chaud dont l'as
rome attire irrésistiblement
les voyageurs ils auraient péri au pays
des algues ensorcelé s'il a fait du
voile de la mariée prévenus par les
oiseaux n'était venu le secourir
finalement il parvint tellement épuisée
au pays du riz qui tomba évanoui au beau
milieu des cgpi de riz tant espéré à son
réveil il vit que l'on s'était occupé de
lui il était allongé sur un lit de
paille de riz comme on le lui
expliquerai plus tard un bol rempli de
petits grains
odorant l'attendait il y goûtent à et
trouva cela tellement six ponts que le
manger goulûment il se sentit alors
ragaillardi est prête à aller à la
rencontre des habitants du pays dure et
quand il les huttes rouve et le jeune
homme leur dit combien la princesse de
son pays allait mal et avait besoin de
sucres lents les riziers qui sont les
habitants du pays on cultive le riz
explique air qu'ils n'en avaient pas
mais se nourrissait de riz et que cela
leur avait toujours bien réussi jusque
là sourit leur expliqua que le riz est
un sucre lent tous rire de bon coeur et
lui fournir tout le riz dont il avait
besoin pour guérir à la princesse il
promit de revenir et de leur faire
découvrir le sucre de son pays
ghislain revin hop et du sucre les
sacoches remplis de riz et la tête
pleine de cette belle rencontre
après avoir avalé bonne quantité de riz
ombrines retrouve à toutes ses forces
pour le récompenser d'avoir sauvé sa
fille leroy nomma ghislain chevaliers du
sucre d'orge le courageux jeune homme pu
ainsi demandé la main de sa princesse
bien aimé
les noces de la princesse ombrines et du
chevalier ghislain furent célébrés
quelques mois plus tard les habitants du
pays du riz ils furent invités et
participèrent ainsi à la fête il
repartir avec de merveilleux souvenirs
et les sacoche remplie de sucre
ombrines et ghislain vécurent heureux et
eurent sept enfants le plus jeune
benjamin ressemblait beaucoup à son père
il était très généreux et très courageux
peut-être le retrouverez vous bientôt
dans de nouvelles aventures